ils sont venus pour lui le viaduc le
temps d'un week-end un aller retour
marseille millau juste pour voir un pont
c'était important de voir cette oeuvre
d'art parce que pour nous c'était nafana
bien ceux des banques
pas de tourner français mais on a des
raisons d'être fiers donc par conséquent
on va effectivement ont participé à
cette fierté à lanvollon viaduc
ça c'est ça qui me c'est ce que nous a
fait venir le sourire grâce au viaduc le
tourisme dans la région a explosé ses
chambres d'hôtes ont ouvert il ya un an
depuis elle ne désemplissent pas une
véritable aubaine pour les heureux
propriétaires pour une période
d'ouverture où c'est vrai qu'on n'était
pas encore connue on a eu un taux de
remplissage qui était inespéré
on peut le dire ce qu'on appelle nous
ici les faits via du côté circulation
c'est aussi leur surprise pour cette
première année de mise en service
près de quatre millions et demi de
conducteurs ont emprunté le viaduc ses
20% de plus que ce qui était prévu ça
économise du temps ça coûte un peu cher
pour le le péage peut-être on a fait un
bon parce que c'est quand même
l ouvrage quoi pour les ouvriers elle
verra partir quand même ça
effectivement construire le plus haut
pont du monde a été une grande aventure
pour les 600 ouvriers
cela a même changé la vie de christian
le mellec une fois le chantier terminé
il a décidé de rester loin de le voir de
le sentir dès respirer avec tous les
joueurs que je veux voir et pourquoi ces
sept ans vous mange pas il ya des choses
à ericsson explicable à millau on
s'apprête à fêter noël dans la sérénité
car depuis un an on respire enfin
les bouchons qui engorgent est la ville
ont disparu c'est d'abord ça le premier
miracle du viaduc